え あの少々私もあまり知らない
現代的な機械をいじろうと思って
ちょっと今日はおいしく作ることには朝から頑張って時間なくなってしまって大変申し訳ないです
で あの今日のテーマは
あの なんかまあ面白おかしく作ったテーマですけどね
まあ信じるものは騙されると
で まあなんでそういうことを作ったかというと
皆様ご存知のように まあ信じる者が救われるという
まあ一般的な世の中で言われていることがございますので
で まあ逆を言ってるんですね
救われるどころか騙されてしまいますよと
で で 別にあの 誰かに対して私たちは恨んでいるわけでも
腹が立っているわけでもなく
あの 信じるというこのことについて
あの人間に起きているいろいろ様々な問題と
それからまあ お釈迦様が皆様ご存知のように
宗教というものを語ったと
まあ思っていらっしゃるし
で また宗教の世界の まあまあ
最大宗教の一つになって
今は 3番目ぐらいになってますけどね
前は 1番目でしたけどね
で これからまあ順番が下がっていって
ゼロにもなりますけどね
で 一応まだまだ世界で 3番目ぐらいにもなっているし
ですから 宗教には欠かせない言葉っていうのは
信仰 信じることなんですね
ですから お釈迦様はどのようにその問題について語っているかと
今日はちょっと考えています
で 仏教の世界においても
この大変 この宗派によって信仰というものは
まあかなり活動している
信仰でないとなりたてないぐらいの宗派でも
仏教の中にもあります
うん まあ多かれ少なかれなんとか信じるということがございます
そういうことで 一応話はあっちこっち行きますから
作ってきたこのメモに沿って説明していきます
で まあ一応いろいろ文字の間違いとか
今日は朝ずっと焦って打ちましたから
いろいろ文法の間違いと文字の間違いいろいろありますけど
まあそれは皆様方各自で訂正しながら読んでください
いわゆる初期仏教の立場
信じるというと 英語で大体使っている言葉だが
ビリーフという言葉とフェースという言葉なんですね
ビリーフといえばあまり一般的に使っているんですね
まあ本当のことについてあっても
ビリーフという言葉を使います
けど フェースといえば宗教的な信仰ですね
そういう働きについて
まあ初期仏教の立場 まあ最初に 1番目
こちらで書いているのは
この で こちらの 1番目なんですけど
意義ですね 意義というか意味ですね
一応言葉っていうのは
ほんの少々定義していないと我々は誤解しやすいんですね
だから この定義っていうのは
その喋る人の勝手なことで
必ずしもそうなる必要はないんです
ですから 私は信仰というと
こういう風な意味で考えているんだと
他の方々は他の考え方を持っているかもしれません
ですから そこ書いたのは
この神様とかね 神々 それから呪術
祈祷 それからまだまだ他の迷信
いろいろありますね そういうのは信じること
で 要はまあこれは正しいかと明確に成立することは不可能ですと
そういうことなんです
ですから 信仰というと
あの 何かこの確かめることはできない
例えば神様がいるかいないかということは確かめる方法はありません
仏となんで平仮名で書いたかというと
日本ではだいたい一般的に仏様を信じているんだという信仰があるんだけど
何を信じているんですかということをはっきりしていないんですね
そういうすごい曖昧で大雑把な信仰も世の中にあります
西洋人だったら神様という絶対的な信仰
絶対的な存在を信じるということはありますね
それから我々日本 それからアジアの人々っていうのは
一般的に神々を信じる
神社やら仏閣 そういう感じの神様がいるんじゃないかと思って
そこに行って信仰したりもしますね
そういうことも入っています
それからもう現代人に人気あるのは
この呪術ですか 呪術 こういう呪文とかね
何か力があるんだと 言葉に力あるんだと
そこでオウムとかなんとかマントラを唱えれば瞑想はうまくいくんだとかね
それからいろんな宗教家のところに行って
私をイニシエーションしてくださいと
私に何かマントラを教えてくださいと
そういうふうな宗教活動をなさっている宗教組織もあります
組織もあります そこで入って浸透して
それなりにしきたり取ったところで
内緒で秘密で自分だけの呪文を教えてくれるんですね
そこで人がその呪文をずっと唱えて唱えて
それで精神的に自分が発達していくんだというふうに信頼はしています
でも この呪文自体に 言葉自体に
例えばオウムとかね オームですね
オウムではなくて オウムという言葉
それからまたいろいろ
ギャーテ ギャーテという呪文が言う
皆様覚えているでしょうし
そういうギャーテ ギャーテ
ハラソーがあって 何でしたっけ？ガテーガテーパーラガテーパーラサンガテーボーディスワーハという呪文なんですけどね
まあで それに何か力あるだろうと思うのであって
なぜかとはわからないんですね
なんでオームオームと唱えたところで何かいいことになるかって
それは何のも証明もできません
それから世の中によくあることを祈祷することなんですね
祈祷したら 万事うまく物事行くんだというふうにも思っているんですね
そうやってそういうものは信じる
で 特色としてあるのは
この明確に整理することは不可能である
バファリン 私は例を出すのはいつも出すのはバファリン飲んだら頭痛が治るんですね
それは信じる必要はないんです
事実ですから ご飯を食べたら
お腹が空いている人はお腹が満腹になるんです
私はご飯を信じていますよということは言う必要はないんですね
当たり前のこと 証拠はあるんですね
例えば勉強しないで遊んじゃったらバカになりますよと
それは将来のことを言ってますけど
そういうことは信仰に入りません
なぜならば いくらでも証拠はあるんですね
そうなるんだということは
何とかして証明することもできるんですね
そうやっていかなる理由もない
証明することには何のこともできません
例えば 西洋ではいまだに神様は絶対的に確実に存在するんだよということは決して証明できません
もし証明したならば それもまた考え方おかしいんですね
人間に証明できる存在ではないんだから
すべてを乗り越えている存在だから
人間には把握できることもできませんし
考えることもできませんし
いくら考えたっても いくら哲学を作ったっても
単なる人間の考え方ですから
それでもって神がいるということは言えません
ですから 西洋ではよく頑張りますけど
神様が確実にいるんだということは証明するために
その努力も本当は無意味なんですね
証明不可能なんです だから
残っている唯一の方法は信じることだけなんですね
信じておっしゃっている通りにやってくださいと
それだけではなくて もう一つありますね
例えば自分では理解できない
あるいは理解不可能なもの
いろいろあります 人の話とか
まあ信じてしまっちゃう
例えば誰かが まあ霊で言えばわかります
誰かがあのトンネルのそばに幽霊が出ますよと言ったら
私も信じますよと あんた見たことがあるけど
私には見えませんと 私には見えませんだけど
人を言うんだから信じると
やっぱり幽霊が出るんだとかね
その場合も 自分で信じたければ
自分でそのトンネルのところに行って
その時間でじーっと見張っていて
自分で目で見たところで信じる必要はないんでさ
見たんだと やっぱり幽霊がいるんだ
そこで考えたってもいいんだけど
仏教ではそれだけでは足りませんだけどね
見たものは本当に幽霊かないかと
まだ確かめなくちゃいけないんだけど
そこまでいかなくたっても
自分で見たならばいいんだけど
我々はほとんど自分でも見ていないのに
人の話を信じちゃうんですね
で よくあることは このまあ
このノストラダムスの予言
ものすごいたくさん信じる人がいて
今ちょっと声が低く低くしちゃったんですね
だから随分先から私はそれをからかっていたんだけど
ありえない そんなことはと
霊能者の言葉とかいっぱいありますね
そこで私にはこの霊が見えますよ
この霊はこう言ってるんだよと言ったら
ああ そうですかと じゃあおそばをお供えしましょうと
それから この見えた霊に
霊能者に見えた霊におそばを分け添えたりだとかするんですね
そうやってもういろいろ霊が乗り移るとしゃべるとか
で そういう場合も 我々はそれを信じるということを他のやり方はないんです
で そういうふうにこの概念もいろいろ信じてしまっちゃう
それから この形而上学的な
この哲学思想 いろんなへんところな形而上学的なことをみんな使っているんですね
作っているんですね 例えば
昔々のギリシャ哲学では
ものにはこの基準的な形はどこかにあるんだと
人間でいえば 人間の基準になる正しい形はどこかに
天国がどこかにあるんだとかね
それはもう基準であって
それとぴったし合わないんだけど
人間いろいろできてるとかね
例えば愛といえば 愛の理想的な状態はもう愛の神様として天国にいるんだと
怒り 憎しみ 戦いにしたっても
そうやって神々が出てる
そうやってもうどこかに天国に何かの理想的な形があるんだと言ったら
それはわからないし 信じるしかないんです
だから形而上学も結局は
信仰というふうなことに入ってしまっちゃうんですね
それからそこに作り変えますけど
だいたいみんな人間には霊魂があるんだ
魂があるんだと 人は死んでも魂は死にませんよと
と頑固と信じているんですね
仏教の世界にしたっても
あの人は成仏しましたと
仏の世界で安らかにいるんだと
もう何のことなく 何の疑いこともなく気楽に言うんですね
この気楽に言うんだけど
結局はそれは信じているんですね
だから成仏させるという抗議
抗議じゃなくて 何と言いますか
という働き こういうことまでなさっちゃうしね
だからどこかで人間に魂
霊魂があるんだというふうな
まあ形はどっちでもいいんですけど
まあ何か死なない 消えない何かあるんではないかと
まだ信じている 証拠はないんです
そのようなものを我々はいっぱいものは信じています
次の問題は そんなことを信じたっても
別にどうってことないんですかと
面白いじゃないかと  UFOを信じるはと
異星人を信じると ノストラダムスの予言を信じると
占いを信じると おまじないも信じるんだと
呪術 祈祷なども信じるんだと
面白いんだと というふうに思うこともできますでしょうし
別にいいんじゃないかと
問題は別にいいんじゃないかということでもないんです
いろいろ危険があるんですね
で 信じることの基本 それから私はこのファンクションですか
機能として書いているものがございまして
ちょっと待ってください
この 2番目に書いたもの
信じることでどのような働きがありますかと
1番目 信じることは まず自分がそのことを知らない
理解していない 理解できないという無知に基づいているんですね
自分が知ってるんだったら信じる必要ないんです
お腹が空いてるんだったらご飯食べなさいよと
私は信じませんよという人はいませんね
知ってるんだから 知ってることは当たり前のことを言う必要ないんだと
だから信仰の問題はそこにあるんですね
知らないことを大事にするんですね
無知であること だから信仰を応援すると
何を応援しているかというと
人間の愚かさを応援しているんですね
だから私たちはそれにちょっとケチをつけてるんです
何か言葉抜けてますね
場だけもう入ってますね
2番目なんですけど で
まあこれはもしちょっと私も覚えてない
何かここで何か抜けちゃったんですけど
あの  言い換えれば支配されたことになります
というふうに入れば意味通る
ああ そうですね 言い換えればでした
ありがとうございます
上に行っちゃったんです
言い換えれば無知 無知に支配
無知 まあいろいろ もうなんか変になってますね
あ これ混乱してるんですね
これは上に行って言い換えれば無知に支配
これ全くダメだ  支配が下に行って支配
それは言い換えれば無知に支配されることになりますから
これダメだ これは使えない
まあとにかく言い換えれば
まあ我々は無知に支配されたことになります
覚えているんだからしゃべります
信じると結局無知に支配されることになりますね
だから仏教はそれにはちょっとまあ気をつけろと言ってるんですね
それから我々は信仰によって私たちの生き方を変えるんでしょうに
もし幽霊やら霊魂やらね
死んだ お化けになって人に邪魔するんだとかね
信じたったら 我々の生き方はそれによって変えるんでしょうに
ノストラダムスの予言を信じてしまったら
みんなあの世紀末で自分の命を守るために
いろんな道具やら何かシェルターやら探したりするんですね
その生き方が変えるんでしょうに
だから無知に支配されて
その上生き方まで変えちゃうんです
それは大変危険ではないかなと
例えば 私はＡという神様は絶対的な神だと信じているんだと思ったら
そのＡという神様を信じていない人々に対して
なんかすごい失礼に あの邪教だと
異教だと扱って その人々をいじめたり
悪いことをしたりする可能性はあります
例えば この法医学やら星占いやら
そういうものを信じたら
仕事に行く前にもちょっと占ってみようかなという風になってしまう可能性もありますね
それで  7時半に出発したらダメだと
9時に出発しないといけないと占いが出てきたら
その人はちょっとディレンマに陥っちゃうでしょうね 9
時に出たらものすごく遅刻する
7時に出たらちょっと危険な目に遭う
不幸になると じゃあどうしようかと
やっぱり遅刻するのは怖いんだから
7時に出かけますよと出かけても
心のどこかですごい不安がある
残っている だから その 1日は大変不安定な 1日になってしまっちゃう
逆に じゃあ9時に まあどうしようもない
7時に出かけたら不幸だから
じゃあ9時に出かけますよと出かけたところで
もう遅刻して そこでひどい目に遭う
遅刻したんだと だから我々の生き方はかなりコントロールしちゃうんですね
この無知に基づいた信仰によって
だから これは冗談の話じゃないんです
やっぱり危険ではないかなと
それにものすごい面白いエピソードがありまして
で あるインドの物語なんですけど
ある女の人がお嫁に行こうと思って
で 話し合って また旦那さんに会ったこともないし
もうかなりインドだから国が大きいしね
で 話し合って もう男の人もじゃあいいですよと
とも決めたんですね そこでお嫁に一旦出たら
また二度と帰ってこないんだから
親たちが大変心配して占い師を頼んだんだそうです
星占い師を  インドよくよく一般的な人気あるんですからね
そこで占い師たちがいろいろ占いを計算してみたら
あんたはこの日にちでは出かけてはいけませんと
で 不幸になるんだと 言って
他の日にちに決めちゃったんですね
今みたいに電話でもして連絡を取ることはできませんし
そこで占いで大変不幸だとね
あの なんとか出るんだったらしょうがないと
いきなりここでスケジュールを変えちゃったんですね
そこで男の人がお嫁さんが来るんだ来るんだと待っていて
待っていて なかなか来ない
次の日も来ない 途中で何があったっても
次の日ぐらいは来られるでしょうに
そこでやっぱり向こうは
何て言いますか 考え方が変わったでしょうと思って
せっかく自分も結婚の準備したんだから
そこら辺の他の女の人をお嫁にもらったんです
その話を聞いて あの女の人はがっかりと大変悲しみに陥って
せっかくお嫁に行こうと思ったことはできなくなったと
そこであまりにも悲しんでいる時は
そのことをお釈迦様に報告したところで
お釈迦様は言ったのは
この愚か者たちがね 星やらいろんなごちゃらんことを信仰して
自分の大事なことを忘れてしまっちゃうんだと
不幸になるんだと言って帰ってこられるだけなんですね
ですから この生き方 そうやってスケジュールまで変えたりすると
そこでちょっと危ない
不幸になる可能性はありますね
だから かなり幅広く世の中を考えると
この信仰でもってあの人々がね
不幸になったことっていうのはいくらでもあります
いくらでもあります 例えば戦争中はね
あの子供たちを戦争に出したのも
結局信仰を働かせたでしょうに
出して平気で殺す 死んでもいいんだと
日本でもそういうことはありましたし
イランはイラクと戦争をした時も同じことをやっていましたし
今もいろんな戦争をやっているところでは
宗教に基づいて戦争をやっているところは
やっぱりもう神のために死んでも天国に行くんだとかね
言ってあの これは殺す側も不幸でしょうし
殺される側も不幸でしょうに
だからそういうことは普通常識な世界では認めるべきかと
今も世の中にあるんですよ
宗教性に基づいて戦争をするっていうことは
原理主義者とかね だから自分たちが神様を信じているんだから
子供たちなんですよ この国連でも禁じられています
18歳ぐらいでもならなきゃ
もう出すなと 私たちから見れば
もう年だから  18歳にしてもまだまだ子供でしょうね
死ぬ年じゃないでしょうね
もうちょっともう親に甘えて
いろいろ親と喧嘩でもしながらね
元気で育ててほしいという一般的な気持ちあるんじゃないんですかね
18歳はまあ男の子っていうのはやっぱり言うことを聞かないわがままで
まあいい加減ですけど
やっぱりそれはまたその年はそれはまた可愛いし
親と喧嘩することも そうやって大きくなって大人になったところで
まあ大変いいなのにもう神様のために戦争に行って戦って敵を倒すと
で 死んでも構いませんということで
それでその子がいて相手を殺す
で 逆に自分も殺されると
どちらでも不幸なんですね
で 元にあるのは決して証明することはできない何かを信じることなんですね
だから人を騙して何かやらせる場合は
一番簡単なからくりは信仰を使うことなんですね
それにやられちゃったらもう逃げ道がないんです
あんた神を批判しているんですか？ということになっちゃうんですね
ですから やっぱり危ないんじゃないかなと
それから この C に書いたポイントに行きます
異なることを信じる人に対しても寛容的になりなりにくいんですね
もともと証明できないものを信じているので
自分が信じているものを固く
また頑固で信じ続けなくてはならない
宗教史上起きた様々な争い
殺戮などが根拠のない信仰の結果ではないでしょうか
ということで それまた信仰の人その特色なんですね
信じるんだったら 徹底的に頑固で信じなくちゃいけないんです
曖昧は認めないんです
信仰の世界では 徹底的に信じなくちゃいけないんですね
でも 徹底的に信じるための証拠はない
だから信仰というんだからね
そうすると 全く違うことを信じている人に対しては
どんな立場を取るべきかというと
もう喧嘩するしかないんですね
あなたの言うことにも一時いくらかの論理ありますよということはできません
ということは ある信仰者に私が言ったのは
彼がすごく威張って 自分たちがすごい道徳的な生き方をしているんだと私に言ったんですね
いろいろ言ったら 私はかえって言ったのは
まああんた方はね 軽々と道徳を守ってますけど
私たちは厳密に守っているんだと
あんた方は人を愛するんだけど
敵を憎しむんだと 我々は敵まで愛するんだと
あんた方は人を殺してはいけないと言うんだけど
我々はもうアリ一匹も殺せませんと
だから何ですか？と言ったら
まああんた方は頑張っているんだけど
地獄に落ちるんだと それで
答えはそういう答えなんです
なぜかというと もうその
その人の信仰は信仰していないだからなんです
ですから 寛容的じゃないんですよ
例えば私は仏教徒で 嘘を言わないと
友達がキリスト教で その方も嘘を言わないんだと
それはいいんじゃないか
我々 2人も嘘を言わないと
それはたとえキリスト教であろうとも
たとえイスラム教であろうとも
どんな宗教であろうとも
嘘を言わないということは素晴らしいことだよことだなと認めることはできなくなっちゃうんですね
いくらなんでもあんたは私の神を信じていないんではないかと
それは一番大きな罪ではないかということで
このこの性格的にすごいこの硬くなっちゃうんですね
この寛容ということは
仏教ではものすごく大事にするんです
これは寛容 英語ではトレランスという言葉ですけど
で 世の中の人々はいろんな意見
いろんな概念持ってます
それどんな概念でも絶対的に正しいということをはっきりと言うこともできないんです
それでもって概念でもって人は戦うべきじゃないんです
殺すべきじゃないんです
例えば この今 インドネシアで起きているでしょうに
政治的なことでものすごいもう建物を燃やしたり
人をいじめたり いろんなことをやっているんですね
東ティモールでいっぱい人を殺したりもしましたし
だから自分たちの考え方
自分たちの政党っていうのはね
それはもう正しいんだと
他の人は潰せと で インドネシアでたくさん投票で選ばれたメガワティさんを選べなかったんだよね
大統領として それで日本のテレビを見ていると
えらいインテリの人々は素晴らしいと言っていたんだから
だからその言葉を聞いた途端
あ これだったらダメやと
インドネシアもダメになるんだと思ったんですけど
まあこちらの考え方も知ってるんだからね
結局 国民が選んだ人は誰かのグループが気に入らないんだから選べないんだと
メガワティさんはなんか得体知れない怪しい人物なんですけど
何を考えているさっぱりわからない
それでもしょうがないでしょうに
国民が選んだならば 一旦 1年ぐらいでもね
じゃあやってみなさいと
ダメだったらもうやめてくださいというのは
当たり前 みんな知ってるんだから
それだったらね そうでもなく
ただ単に他のいろんな考え方で
まあそう追い出すことによって
また不幸が出てくる 国の中の平和がなくなっちゃう
ですから もう政治的なことを言うならば
皆様知っている言葉を借りて言うならば
自民党であろうが 民主党であろうが
社会党わかりませんだけど
もう共産党であろうが
まあそれぞれ人々が自分自分で何か考え方を持ってるだけの
それでもって我々は喧嘩するしたり
相手を侮辱したり 非難したり
ダメな人間やと思ったりするのはまるっきり無意味なんですね
人にはいろいろ好みというものあるし
ですから そこら辺で このものすごい大きな心で寛容的ということ
仏教だったらすごく必要なんですね
それはなくなっちゃうんですね
信じる場合は これは正しいというふうに信じてしまっちゃうんだからね
だから人間の人格はものすごく醜くなって
大変危険な社会ができてくるんですね
今の我々生きている社会も
前の社会も ものすごい問題だらけであったのは
ものすごい大きなポイントっていうのは
この信仰なんです これは宗教的な信仰であろうか
他のこと人を信仰することであろうか
そういうものでもって
お互いに喧嘩したり 殺し合ったり
暴動を起こしたり 平和を壊したり
人をすごい悲しみ 悲しい目に遭わせたりとかね
していけたんですね ですから
まあそこも本当に信仰がやってきてくれた
大変ありがたい結果なんですけどね
で あの まあＤに行ってみましょうか
個人の責任感が薄れていく
自分の幸不幸が他の他によることだと思う
それも信仰にある一つなんですね
それわかりやすいのは
この絶対的に神様を信じる場合は
絶対的な神様を 信じると
自分の運命っていうのはそちらでもう定められているんですね
絶対的なところで なぜならばもうもう過去現在
未来 すべて知ってるんだから
そうすると まあ自分が不幸であろうか
幸福であろうか やっていることは失敗ばっかりであろうか
成功ばっかりであろうか
まあまあ それしょうがないと
自分知ったことではないんだと
ということで 個人の責任感が薄れていくんですね
逆に頑張ればなんとかなるんだよということはなくなっちゃうんです
いくら頑張っても まあ神様に決められているようにしかならないんだと
そうなってしまっちゃうんですね
例えば 誰かがあなたの家は不幸なのは亡くなった誰かがもう呪われているんだと言ったらいきなり
ああ そうですか だったらもう悪霊払いですかね
除霊でもするしか方法ないんだと
何か自分の原因があるかないかとはもう確かめてみないんですね
それはまあ人殺しにも使ってるんです
で あのバグアギータという宗教のテキストがございまして
で そちらで言っているのは
このシャトリア族に生まれたら戦争をするのは神に定められたヤーガですよと
ヨーガですよと ヤーガで言ったって
ヨーガという言葉はご存知でしょう
カルマヨーガ だからシャトリア族で生まれた人は戦争するのはヨーガであって修行であります
ですから もう何のことなく
まあやっちゃえばいいんですね
だってしょうがないんだと
バラモン神様が 私はそういう戦争する王様の親戚の上で生まれるようになってしまったんだから
私の仕事をやればいいと
インドにあるこのカースト制度
人種差別 それはもうそのそちらのこのバグアギータやら
もうそういうこちらの教えからも支えられているんですね
ある面で ウパニシャッドテキストでは人間
生命は平等だと言いながらも
またある面で この人種差別を認める
だから私が言いたいのは
信仰は正しくないか確かめること
私にもできません そんなことないと
そんな神がいませんということを私にさえもできませんよ
なぜならばどうしても証拠をできませんだから
証拠がないということは
あるともないとも言えないということなんです
でも問題はそうじゃなくて
社会に迷惑だと 人間の努力には迷惑だと
それだけは 仏教の一言葉もよく使ってるんですよ
時々不幸になったり いろいろ怪我したり
事故を起こしたり 子供はものすごくよく病気になったりする場合は
まあもし仏教の関係育てならば
まあこれは業だから 業だから
業だからといって業ってあるかないかもわからないでしょうに
証拠は出せないでしょうね
そうすると 業というものを信じて
まあしょうがないと 努力しないんですね
チャレンジしないんですね
だからそれでかなり 問題が起きる
それからイに行きましょうか
で 言ったら信仰を語る人々の組織の犬ままになって
この自由がなくなる それもわかりやすいことなんですね
昔はもうローマ王にカトリック教の信者さんたちは厳密に支配されていたんですね
犬のままで 間違ったことでも言ったならば
もう首も飛んじゃうんですね
大変良くなかったでしょう
だから人間がそれにチャレンジで頑張っちゃったんだからね
西洋の方はね まあキリスト教が現れる前にギリシャ哲学とかね
哲学者もいた文化だから
やっぱりそこら辺 この異端派で自由思想というものは発展して
正統派を破れて 正統派を乗り越えちゃって
今は科学も哲学も自由思想もヨーロッパにあるんですけど
でも正統派は地球は平らですよと
もう絶対的ですよって
なぜならば聖書に書いているんだから
書いてないんだけどね
そんなことを言ったりもしております
で 何か丸いですよと言った人はひどい目に遭う
地球は太陽の周り回っているよと言ったところで
まあかなり苦労しましたと
ですから この 信仰に求めてしまうと
そうやって組織の奴隷になっちゃうんですね
それもう関係ない宗教のことを言ったんだけど
まあ日本に見ても 私こそ神だと
私こそ解脱者だとかね
なんとか言って それからその人の言う通りに
その人のわがままを聞いてあげなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
脅すんです 仏教の世界で言えば
法華経を信じなさいと
信じない連中はみんな邪教だと
だから言われる通りにいろいろなことをやらなくちゃいけないんですね
かなり人間は奴隷にしちゃうんですね
だから信仰でもって実際の人間の社会を見ると
幸せになった例よりは不幸になった例っていうのはもうありつぎなんです
我々 今も過去から今まで生きてきた世界で
地球上で どんな人類にもあったありったけの問題っていうのは
何か変なことを信じる方からでしょうに
今もこのアフリカとかいろんなところでね
女性をものすごく大変な目に遭わせたりする
一つの例なんですけど
すごい悲しいことで 国の名前を忘れちゃったんだけど
この女性を 12 歳ぐらいになっちゃうと
このイスラム教 ユダヤ教で
この男の人は割礼というんですか
吊るという儀式がありますね
で それは男の場合は何のこともないんで
そんなことは 別に必要というわけでもないんだけど
まあやりたければやったってもいいんだけどね
女性にまでそういうことをするんですね
で 男の場合は この私が読んだレポートでは
この男の人を割礼したら
ちゃんとそれなりに治療を与えたりするんだけど
女性にはそれでもしないんだそうです
そこで一生苦しみを味わわなくちゃいけないんですね
だからそれで死ぬ女の子人々もいて
子供を産む時はまあこちらいっぱい怪我させてるんだから
そこで死ぬ人もいたりして
だからそういう女の子たちがもう小さい時も男の
使用物資にしちゃうし
それから あの男と一緒にいることさえもものすごい苦痛だそうです
この器官をもういじってるんだから
だからそれ信仰なんですね
そうでなきゃ良くないんだと
不浄だと あれには国連もいろいろ言って
もうやめなさい やめなさいとすごい活動しているんだけど
それでもやると だからそれは小さなどこかのこり残るということだから
まあ我々はあまり気にしないかもしれませんだけど
世の中どこを見ても そうやって人々をいじめて苦しんだり
苦しめたりすることはいくらでもあり得るんです
いくらでもあってあったし
それから F に書いてるのは
このあの このもう一つ仏教を反対することなんですね
信仰対象 組織と自分の間に絶対的乗り越えない縦の関係が生まれてしまいますね
これは子が絶対的に自由になれないということになります
例えば まあ日本の例で言いますと
どこかの神様を信じているとする
自分もその神様と一緒になるということは絶対的にないでしょうに
我々はその神社に行って御祈りして
なんとかお祓いして帰るだけであって
それは絶対的神を信じる西洋的な宗教にしても
人間は絶対に神にはならないんだと
そうすると神にならない
それから神のメッセンジャーたちもいますね
宗教家たちが 彼らもちょっと上のレベルでしょうに
イエス様とこの 10人の弟子たちがものすごい上レベルでしょうに
これ絶対的に乗り越えられないんですね
だからこの現代新興宗教やらカルト宗教団体を見ても
すごく厳密に信仰という働きを使っているんですね
ですから そこですごい縦の関係が出てきて
人間というのは 自分という個人が永久的な奴隷なんですね
それでよろしいかと なぜ横にならないんですかね
横の関係 お釈迦様はだから昔からあの
このお釈迦様の時代で
この信仰でもって人があまりにも苦しんできたのを見てきたんだから
あまりにも人を苦しんできたのを見てきたんだから
お釈迦様は横の関係を作ったんです
お釈迦様は私は悟り開いて開きましたと
私に並べる生命は誰もいませんと
ブッダですよと言いながら何言うんですか？頑張ってみなさいと
そうなるんだと みんな
そこで初めてこの 60人の方々は出家して悟るんですね
悟ったところで お釈迦様は大変喜んでこういうんです
私も阿羅漢であって いわゆる人格完成してあって
あなた方ももう人格を完成しているんだと
平等なんですね それで
この自由になるメッセージをみんなに言ってあげてくださいと
世の中は大変苦しんでいるんだと
解放してあげなさいと
一人一人で別々な道で歩いて歩んで
このメッセージをね 言ってあげなさいと
だからすごい独立してやって
お釈迦様は絶対的で お釈迦様でなきゃダメということはなかったんですね
だからお釈迦様もそれにはかなりこのあの攻撃的な縦の関係にはね
かなりそれを壊そうと思ってたんです
それから仏教でよく使っていることは
この生きとし生けるものという言葉
サッター衆生 生命という言葉なんですね
全部生命をまとめる そのサッターといえば
衆生といえば 絶対的神であろうがなかろうが
梵天であろうが 神々であろうが
餓鬼幽霊であろうが 地獄にいる鬼たちであろうが
もう人間で虫であろうが
もう何もことなくすべてまとめて一言葉で使っているんです
サッターと だから慈悲の瞑想の場合も
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
ですから 無制限で無料で
限りなくすべての生命
誰も落とすことはしません
だから関係は縦ではなくて横にしているんです
それは生命として まあ一時的に一時的にちょっとした関係は
親がいて子供がいると
その関係は一時的なんです
普遍的ではありません
子供が弱いところは 親は面倒を見なくちゃいけない
親の言うことを子供が聞かなくちゃいけない
それは絶対的ではありません
ですから 今 日本の総理大臣は小渕さんですから
彼が一番偉くて もう彼の考え方の通りに政治やらなくちゃいけない
だからといって これ絶対的というわけじゃないんで
そういうのは一時的なもので
今 我々は人間で威張ってるんだけど
動物やらもう人間のほど力もなくて
生きる権利もなくなって
素晴らしい人間のおかげで
で まあ苦労している でもそういうのは一時的な関係だけなんですね
そこでこの親の関係の場合は
よく言っていることは
だから今 我が子や我が子やとね
しがみついて子供をいじめていたっても
愛情ではなくていじめですけどね
いじめていたっても もし母親が先に死んじゃったら
他のところで生まれ変わっちゃうでしょうね
それで別に自分の子でもなんでもないんですね
ここで集めたんだから
そういう関係できたんであって
他の次元で集めたら違う関係でしょうし
ですから この一時的な関係は仏教は否定してないんです
親もない 子供もないとかね
親は偉くもない みんな平等ですよということは言ってないんですけど
先生も生徒も平等ですよと
だから先生言うことは生徒を聞く必要ないんだとかね
そういう屁理屈を言ってるわけじゃないんです
教室があるならば そこで一時的に先生が偉くて
生徒は話を聞けということの関係は生まれますけど
そういうものは一つも宗教的な関係でもないし
真理としての関係でもありません
すべて一時的 夫婦はお互いに仲良くしなくちゃいけないんだと
そういうのは夫婦である限りなんですね
離婚しちゃったら別にどうったことないんで
離婚してからも旦那さんに食事の用意しなくちゃいけないってことはないんだから
それでその関係は消えます
ですから 人間の関係とかね
人間 他の生命のいろいろ関係あるんだけど
すべて一時的 ですから
仏教でも神々はいませんとは言ってないし
神々もいるということは言ってますけど
たとえ神々がいたっても
彼らは絶対的に偉いというわけじゃないんです
とりあえず今 神だから私よりはちょっといいところにいるんじゃないかと
それだけなんです でも
神も自分の業が終わって死んじゃったら
どこに生まれ変わるのかわからないんだと
神も自分の徳の力がなくなっちゃったら
死んでしまって地獄に落ちる可能性もありますと
仏教でも地獄という考え方はあるし
一般的な仏教では だからと言って地獄のうちだったら永久的だと
そうじゃないんですね
永久的ではないんですね
地獄のうちであっても
この悪いことを終わったら
悪いやった悪いことのエネルギーが終わったら
またそこから立ち上がって他のところに生まれ変われる
だから私たちは人間であろうとも
あんまり威張らないのが仏教のやり方なんですね
全く威張ってはいけない
例えばもう一緒に生活している人の中で
一人が頭が悪いんだと
あんたバカですよ 頭が悪いですよと
いじめるのはものすごい
仏教から見れば これは真理に反しているんです
その人は一時的でたまたまバカだけなんですね
バカですよという人が一時的で
たまたま口うるさいだけなんですね
頭いいとは思ってないんだから
私はだいたい 頭いい人はそんなこと言わないんだからね
だからたまたま口うるさいだけなんですね
それですぐ帰っちゃうんですね
そういうのは だから どんな立場にいたっても
その立場は一時的ですよと
だからもう比較することもできないし
もう絶対ものすごい幅広い寛容的な心を作った方がいいんですね
自分が人間だとも威張れない
それから動物なんか見て
ああ まあ虫だから嫌ですよとか
ゴキブリだから嫌ですよと
そうやって差別的な気持ちも作れない
外国人だから嫌ですよとかね
そういうのはもう成り立たないんですね
すべて一時的 こんなちょっとのこと
そういう風な信仰のファンクション
働きあって まあ私はそれに信仰に対して反対的なことを言ってますから
そういう信仰の悪いところだけ
まあ徹底的に出してしまいましたけどね
信仰はそれでも素晴らしいと思う人にとっては別に思わない
思われないかこともはないんです
信仰で救われたという人もいることはいるんだけどね
だから  １億人に一人が信仰に救われたっても
1億人ももう騙されて苦労はしているんです
それだけは確かなんです
信仰で自分の病気治ったと言っても
治らなかった人々の方がものすごい数が多いんですね
だから 統計的に客観的に見ると
やっぱり悪口言うしか言うようもないんです
まあそこまでは一応信仰に対する考え方
よく覚えてほしいのは
信仰っていうのは無知
ありがたがっちゃうと
自分が無知をありがたがっちゃうんです
だから仏教においてはちょっと認めにくいんですね
仏教っていうのは智慧の教えということだから
ブッダっていうのは智慧を完成した人という意味ですからね
だから仏教を実践する方々からお釈迦様は何を求めていますか？智慧
智慧を育てなさいと それさえあれば問題解決するんだと
わかる人は問題を作りませんだから
山に行ったっても 道がわかっている人は迷子にならない
わからない人は迷子になる
簡単なことなんです そういうことだから
仏教ではやっぱり認めることはできません
それでまあいきなりもう変えます
仏教の立場にいきます
あの有名な教えがありまして
これはカーラムスットといいますけど
このアングッタルニカイトというテキストに入ってあって
テキストの 2番目入ってるんですけど
まずストーリーを少々理解してください
でお釈迦様がある町に行ったんですね
行ったら その町にはすごいこの知識人たちがいっぱいいたんです
その人々があまりお釈迦様の話は聞くことはあまり面白くなかったんです
話をする前に で その人々はこう言ったんです
我々の村にはね いろんな宗教の人々が来るんだと
来て 自分の教えはこういう教えですよ
こういう教えですよと徹底的に言うんだと
言って 他の人々の教えは全くダメで間違っているんだよと
でもう一人の人が来て
自分の教えはこういうこと
それこそ正しいんだ 他の人々の教えは全くダメやと言うんだと
そうやってお互いに正反対の思考いっぱいあるんですね
ある人は運命を語っていて
すべて運命で決めているんだと
ある人は運命はまるっきり否定すると
ある人はもう人が死んじゃったら永久的にどこかに行くんだと
ある人は人は死んじゃったらまるっきり終わりだと
そこで自分の言うことだけ正しいんだと
他の人の教えは間違っていると
まあ言うんですよと だから我々はもう誰の話も相手にしないんですよと
お釈迦様に言うんです
私たちはね 人の話なんか相手にしません
いい加減でね どっちかわからないんだからと
言われたら お釈迦様はどう思っておっしゃったかというと
その通りですよと あなた方は素晴らしく疑うべきことを疑っているんだと
その通りですよと 正しいんだと
みんな疑っていること
信仰しないこと 正しいと言って
何か理解するときはどのように理解するべきかと
理解する方法 いわゆる信仰する方法ではなくて
ものをわかる時は人はどこらへんに気をつけるべきかと
お釈迦様は認識学を喋ったんです
認識論 ですから 我々は何かを認識するときは危険なものはいっぱいあります
この危険なものはやめましょうと
ですから そこで智慧の方法ですね
知識ともいいし 認識論でもよろしいし
お釈迦様はもう私の言うことを信じなさいということではなくて
認識論を語ってしまったんですね
そこでやってはいけないことはいくつか言ったんです
1番目 マアヌッサヴェーナ
それインドであったことだから
皆様方はあまりわからないかもしれません
この日本訳は 私は随分焦って勝手に書いたものだから
決して適切ではないんです
これ 全部作ったのは今日の朝なんです
昨日夜作ろうと思ったんだけど
まあ 1時半  2時ぐらいになってくると
これ朝までやっちゃいそうと思ってやめちゃったんですけど
ですから 朝作ったんだから
一応もうかなり問題点があるかもしれません
マアヌッサヴェーナ 一応神の言葉
聖典などを真理の基準にしないこと
そんなものは真理の基準にしない
マっていうのはいけませんということ
アヌッサっていうのは
やっぱり聞いたという意味なんですね
誰に聞いたかというと
神に聞いたんです これでこのヴェーダ聖典を非難しているんです
お釈迦様は自分の社会の問題のことを語っていたんだから
まあやっぱりブラフマン人たちが
自分たちには秘密の聖なる経典があるんだと
その経典は神様から直接聖人たちの耳元で言ったんだと
神の告げ ある人に言う
そしてある人がみんなに喋ると
それで言われた人があるいはそれテキストを作ったりもする
それでみんな これ神の告げだから信じましょうということにいきなり信じてしまっちゃう
もしこれ神の言葉でと言ったならば
仏教徒だったらだったら信じませんと
結構ですと言うんです
それで捨てます 要りませんと
なぜかというと 正しいかないか確かめる方法まるっきりないんですね
それで事実になるわけじゃない
たとえ聖書に書いているんだからといって
それで真理だよということは成り立たないんです
たとえ神の言葉だと言ったっても
結構嘘を言うんだから
神も なぜかというと このもう十年ぐらい前かな
このマリア様がどこかに二
三か 四か所ぐらいで現れて現れて
それからオーストラリアにも三か所に現れちゃって
そのテキストまで作ったんだよ
人々は 言って この赤松なんですね
それで日にちも決めて
この日にちには神様が降りてくるんだと
で 私は冗談で考えるのは
このキリスト教の方々だったら
神様が降りてくることは一番ありがたいことなんですけど
みんな怖がるんですね
なんで怖がるかと  それは置いておいて
そこで その日にちは その宗教だけ信じる人々はみんな集めていたんです
それで何も起こりません
そこでこの神がかりの人がいきなりマリア様がその計画を中止しましたと
後で次の日は教えるんだそうですと
で 帰ってくださいと 欧西の人々に言うんですね
だから人を馬鹿にすることもいい加減にしなさいと
私だったら言うんだけど
みんなそうですか はい
わかりましたと解散するんですね
信仰は捨てません だから論理的に考えれば
マリアさんがそんなに神だったら
自分で決めた日にちにこれ実行できないとぐらいわかるでしょうに
たとえ隕石がぶつかって地球は破壊するんだと言ったっても
我々にも私にはできませんだけど
それなりの数学できる人にとっては計算して
日にちだけではなくて
時間場所まで言えるでしょうに
この場所にこの時間に落ちるんだと
神様にはできないんです
だから信じるのはもう馬鹿しか信じないと思いますけど
そんなことは  お釈迦様最初にもこの聖典などはまあ真理の基準にするなということなんですね
２番目  パランパラヤ パランパラっていうのは伝統的な知識ですね
伝統的で信じてくるもの
昔からの言い伝えを真理の基準にしないと
昔から我々はそのふうにやってきたんだとかね
だから何でしょうかと
2, 000 年間もずっとやってきたんだと
それで真理になりますかね
ならないはずなんですね
ですから 言い伝え 昔からの言葉とかね
というのも別に基準にしないこと
間違っている 自分でわかったらもうやめればいいんです
伝統とかね 伝統だと思って思っておかしいことをやっている時いっぱいあるでしょうに
昔からやっているんだからといって
くだらんことをバカバカらしいことをいっぱいやっているでしょうに
3番目 マアイティキラヤ
これはお釈迦様はあまり専門用語を使わないんです
一般的にすごい一般的な言葉でお話をするんです
だから イティキラヤというのは
まあおそらくこうではないか
もしかするとこうではないかとかね
そうやって曖昧で このようではないかという
guess work ですね
guess guess
って何ですか？日本語で
推測 まあ推測よりも軽いんですね
まあ例えばこのカードを遊ぶ時は
カードも片面片ではなくて
表を下にして置いて じゃあ金を探せと言ったら
じゃあこれだと それは推測はできませんね
そんなような曖昧なんですね
ただ当ててみるだけ 推測は後から来ます
まあ子供の時 いろいろ遊びでやるでしょ
例えば何かコインでも何か手で持ってもよく見せて
で こうやってある手に入れて
手を隠して見せる じゃあどんな手にありますか？と
当てるだけですからね
その場合は これだと 私は昔やったのは石なんか拾って
じゃあどちらか当ててみなさいと
で 向こうは本当に石が入っているものを当てちゃうと
するっとこの石を落としちゃうんです
じゃあ負けと ですから
まあそういうのは悪い遊びですけど
とにかくあの そうやってこのこうではないかという曖昧さも真理の基準にしてはいけませんと
4番目 マアピタカサンパダーネーナ
ピタカっていうのはテキストのことなんです
ピタカ テキストのことなんです
テキストにあるんだから真実ですかね
そういう傾向も人間にあるんですね
何かとかテキストから出しちゃって
だから真実やと そうじゃないんです
いくらなんでもいろんなテキストに書いているものは
後でそうではないということはわかることいっぱい世の中にあるでしょうに
だからテキストになったということは
決して真理の基準になりません
それも否定する そちらは拠点と書いてましたからね
だいたいこの拠点に古いテキストに書いているものは信じる傾向は強いんです
捨てろと そういうことを 5
番目 マアタッカヘート
言う人はかなり理屈 ものすごい理屈ばっかりしゃべっていると
理屈だから理屈に合うんだからといって信じる必要はないんですね
まあ理屈も2種類に分けてます
お釈迦様が 理屈というのは単なるもうもうほとんど言葉の遊びで
概念の遊びで あの まああまりいいことではないんですね
理屈では何とも何でも言える時もありますからね
で  6番目 マアナヤヘート
ナヤっていうのはこのそれよりもうちょっとマチな論理なんですね
でも純粋論理あの あの
何でしたっけ このシンボリックロジックみたいな感じで
だからこの間の金曜日の勉強会でも説明しましたから
A イコール B というのは純粋論理としては成り立ちますけど
実際には成り立ちませんと
実際の世界では 紙の上では
紙の上では A イコール B というのは成り立ちます
故に B イコール A とも言えます
でもあれは真理ではありません
で 実際の我々の証拠を出してみると A
イコールBという証拠は一つもないんです
一つもないんです なのに数学では純粋論理ではAイコールBということは成り立つ
もしAイコールBというのは真実であるんだったら
どうぞ 私はあまり論理を勉強してないんだけど
教えていただいたっても構いませんだけど
私は言うのはそれは成り立ちません
例えばリンゴを一つ持ってきて
もう一つリンゴを持ってきて
まあこれは同じだよということはできます
でも 一つのリンゴにAと言うと
もう一つのリンゴにもAと言うしか方法ないんです
それはBではありません
だからAと名付けたのは何かあるんだからAと言ったんであって
何かあるんだからBと言ったんであって
だからAイコールBにはならないんです
なぜならば AはAでBはBだから
例えばAは2であると A
の値は Bの値も2であると言っちゃうと B
使う必要ないんですね
そこでダブって間違っちゃうんです
でも数学ではそんなことは当たり前なんでしょ
だから実際の世界では成り立たないことなんですね
そうやって論理 純粋論理を持ってきたっても
それは真理の世界ものになりません
私は昨日例で出したのはスマナサーラはスマナサーラですと
何の意味もないでしょうに
それはAイコールBということと同じなんですね
例えばスマナサーラは田中ですと言っちゃったら
これは×でしょうに スマナサーラは田中ではありませんだから
ですから 純粋論理もお釈迦様はこの真理として置いておきなさいと
嫌になっていると思いますけど
またあります それでは
それでは 7番目 マハーカラパリタッケー
形式 理屈的ということを形式が
この形式論務 まあまあ
西洋でもありますけどね
あの 数学ではよくありますね
形式いろいろ使ったりする
形式 形 いろいろ理屈で考えて
パリビタッカっていうのはものすごい考えるということなんですね
あの難しい数学の問題とか
まあ皆様まあ数学上手だから得意
しょうね あれはもう頭で遊んでいるだけで
別に実際にする だからそこを真理とかね
そういうものは実際の世界があるということはないんです
まあ私の知識で言えば
例えばまあ １を３で割っていくと
数学の世界では無限 でも実際の世界では何のことなくもある ３
分に切ることはできる
数学ではデシマルにしちゃうと不可能
まあですからね で あまりそういう形式的な論理も使ってはいけませんと
8番目 まあバッバルーパターエ
可能性 可能性にもかかるなと
まあそういう可能性もありますから
信じますよと まあ例を言います
例えば地球は破壊するんだと
まあそういう可能性は普通
科学的に考えたってもね
ありますね 地球は破壊するんだと
それで故に世紀末論を信じる
その可能性にかかるなと
地球は破壊するということはまああり得る
そう使って だからあんた
どうやって世紀末を否定するんですかと
といったって 私だけかもしれません
だけど 私はあれはもう真っ向から否定していますけどね
だから そうやってこの可能性にもかかってはいけません
8番目は言った  9番目
マーディッキニッジャーナカンティア
それはよくあります 自分の意見に合っているということ
基準にしない 私たちは自分の意見に合うことを言った途端
あ その通りだとすぐ飛んでいっちゃう
これはまあ どんな人間もやってしまっちゃうんです
おお 同感だ 同感だと 同感だ
でも嘘は嘘ですよ 真理にならん時はならんです
だから自分の見解も置いておきましょうと
で 最後に マーサマノノーガル
サマノっていうのはお釈迦様のことなんです
ノーっていうのは 私たちにとってはガル
とても尊い人だと お釈迦様は私たちにとって尊い人やと思って信じるなと
お釈迦様は自分のことを否定しちゃうんです
あ これは偉大なるお釈迦様がおっしゃっているんだから
やっぱり信じましょうと
そんなことでもうひどい目に遭うんだと
ですから そこで意味は
この語る人のカリスマ性
偉大さも真理の基準にしないこと
なぜならば 偉大なる人も変なことを言う場合あります
そこで真理の基準がないんですかね
ヤートゥンへあったのはじゃあねやったと
ものすごい長い文章なんですけど
自分で確かめて理解することやと
アッタナーは yourself You
have to know by it yourself という意味なんですね
自分で確かめて理解しなさいと
他人に頼るなと 私はブッダだからといってもう信じるな
自分で確かめなさいと
本当かないかと そういうのは仏教ではこの信仰に対してものすごく
こういう風に 厳密に 我々は智慧と知識にはすごい
まあ神経使います だからかすかにでも間違わないようにと
かなり厳密なんです で
その仏教の立場の B にいきましょう
まあほとんど時間もなくなりましたから
少々休憩するならば どうします
か  一応 10 分ぐらい まあみんなもう疲れてるでしょうし
なりますけど まあそれで 10 分ぐらい
じゃああの 2部始まります
あのこれからこのビー
はい あの今 仏教の立場を説明していて
この次のポイント お釈迦様はどれほどあの信じ込むことを断ったかという例なんですね
このパーリ語で書いてますけど
ヴィーマンスケーナビッカレビックーナ
パラッサチェトーパリャンアジャナンテーナ
タターガテサマンネーサナカターッバ
サッマーサンブッドドワノーワーティ
で まあちょっといい加減な訳をしてしまったんだけど
このパーリ文字を打つときはちょっとトラブルも起きちゃって
いろいろ変な文字も入ってますけどね
で ヴィーマンサケーナ
比丘ナ 物事を調べる人
ヴィーマンサカっていうのは
このリサーチャー オブザーバー
オブザーバー もういわゆる物事を探求して探検して本当かないかと確かめる人なんですね
ヴィーマンサっていうのは知恵のことでもありますね
だから知恵のある人 あるいは物事を調べる人
比丘だったら でも パラッサチェトーパリャンアジャナンテーナ
パラッサ あの他人の えっと
これ これ このパラッサ
他人のチェトーパリャン
心のあり様ですね アジャンなんてまだ知らない
他人の心は読めない でも自分で調べたい
それだったらタターガテ
ブッダについてもサマンネーサナカターッバ
チェックしなさいと 調べなさいと
私 お釈迦様の言葉に言えば
私のこともあなた方はちゃんと調べなさいよと
何を調べるんですか？と
サッマーサンブッドドワノーワーティ
サッマーサンブッダですか
いわゆる本当にブッダですか？本当に悟っているんですか？と調べなさいよと
これぐらいの言葉というのは
他のどんな宗教にもないんです
宗教を知る方がそう言うんです
だから いかに仏教はこの知恵に知識にかかっているかっていうことなんです
お釈迦様はそうと 私はもう真理悟りました
もうやること終わったとかね
もう私に並べる人はもういませんとかね
言うんだけど その言葉を権威として使ってはいけませんと
私が言うんだからと信じるなということなんです
自分のことを調べなさいよと
ブッダのことも だから
他人の心を読み取る能力のない比丘は
如来について如来が小学者かないかは観察するべきだと
それぐらいの自由は仏教以外はないんです
ブッダのこともとことん調べてもいいんです
大体このヨーロッパの学者たちが
この東南アジアの仏教に対してすごい共感を持ってるのはそういうことなんですね
ヨーロッパから来て言いたい放題のことを言ったりする
我々やっているしきたり習慣は時々ものすごい散々批判して貶したりもする
でも誰も攻撃しないんです
すごい親切な どうぞどうぞ来てください
どうぞ研究してくださいと
このオープンっていうのは何だろうかと
自分たちが真っ向からいろんなことを批判しているのにとかね
別にお釈迦様の教えの場合
気にしない そんなことは
調べれば このいかに素晴らしいかということはわかるんだと
ですから調べさせた方がいいんです
また 今日忙しくて他の出典出せなかったんだけど
それからあの本ではなくて ＣＤ
で経典持ってる持ってますから
なかなか調べるの難しいんですね
プログラムの間ではなかなか関連性はまるっきりなくて
かなり苦労しなくちゃいけないんだから
もう落としちゃったんだけど
あるところでこう言うんです
ブッダの教えは いわゆる隠れたら気持ち悪いものはいくつかあるんだと
隠れては力がわからないもの
一つは太陽 太陽はものすごい雲で隠れちゃったら
雨雲で太陽のパワーが見えなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから 太陽が雲がない
もうきれいな空だったら
太陽はいかに大胆なものかとわかるんですね
そのようにお釈迦様の教えも
みんなにオープンに批判したい放題批判するために
もう切ったり割ったり何でもいいんです
まあ調べてくださいと
オープンになった方が輝くんだと
力がわかるんだと そこで隠して格好つくものもありますと
一つは女性の恥ずかしいところとかね
女性なんかは体は隠した方がよろしいと
もう一つ 変な教え インチキな教え
そういうのはできるだけ秘密に秘密にした方がもうかっこつけるんだと
だから本当のお釈迦様はかなりきつくからかってますよ
こういう秘密の教え これはもうもう何といいますか
イニシエーションしなきゃ教えてあげませんとか
密教だよと あなた方にはわかりませんよという
そんな威張ることは 女性の生殖器官のように例えているんです
すごいもうけなす言葉なんですけど
お釈迦様は軽々くすごいきついことを教えますから
仏教だったら もう太陽のごとくもうみんなにオープンにしてしまうんだと
だから諸部仏説は決して密教ではありません
まったくかすかにもないんです
秘密の教えっていうのは
それから調べようと思ったっても
お釈迦様のこと どう調べればいいんですかね
こっちでお釈迦様が言うのは
私たちは人の心をそこまで読めるんだったら
他人の心 そういう直接的な能力があるんだったら
人を言ってることは正しいかどうかわかりますけど
そんな能力がないんだったらどうしますかと
だったら調べなさいと
調べる方法を後で延々とこの経典で
この読む方々には  12回の42番目
47番目の経典なんです
日本語訳ありますから
お読みになった方がいいと思います
47番目だろうとちょっとゲスしたんだけど
あのあの 私が使ったバージョンではちょっと言いにくいんです
一応47と思います 47
でなければ48か46
そこら辺なんです で 調べる方法もお釈迦様はちゃんと教えてあげるんだよ
方法論ないと これはディースダンメス
2つのことについて観察します
チャック チャックソッタ
ヴィンニエーース ダンメス
チャックっていうのは目
ソウタっていうのは耳
この情報からいかなくちゃいけないんですね
だから私が知識得る情報資源はほとんど目と耳なんですね
鼻で勉強することはほとんどないでしょうに
そういう学問もありますけど
それはほんの小さい学問なんですね
香水とかなんとか研究する人々は
もう鼻を頼りにしますけど
料理とか研究する人々は
口 味も頼りにしますけど
世の中の大勢の学問っていうのは目と耳頼りにしているんですね
だから やっぱり人に認識手段というのは目と耳なんですね
だからお釈迦様はこの聴覚と視覚と聴覚に関する情報で調べてくださいと
それでやり方を説明しているんです
それで視覚っていうのは
お釈迦様を見ること その人を見る
よくよく見ると 歩き方
食べる方 もう性格 徹底的に観察すると
ああ これは貪瞋痴のある人の生き方ではないと
やっぱり心は清らかでないと
こんな生き方はできませんとわかるだろうと
それからお釈迦様はしゃべる言葉
言葉をよくよく聞いて
どんな愚か者にもそういう話できますかと
で 考えちゃうと なるほど
おそらくお釈迦様には煩悩がないだろうと
煩悩がない人にしかこういう話はしゃべれないんだということはあなた方にわかるだろうと
そういうことで おそらくブッダは悟っているんだという推測はできます
でもかなり情報を取っているんです
だから 自分の宗教の一番ありがたい開祖様でもある一番お釈迦様より偉い人はいないんだからね
そういうお釈迦様のことも調べなさいよと
堂々と出家している比丘たちに言うんですね
だから いかに初期仏教は信仰とは縁のないと
離婚しているということはわかるんです
それでＣに行きます じゃあ
このもうちょっとこのまあ仏教の信は矛盾かということ
なぜならば 皆様方 仏教のことをよく勉強しているんだから
よく信という言葉出てくるんです
仏教に信サッダという悟りに必須な条件があります
これは根拠も疑うこともなく
仏説を権威を教わりとしておのみにすることではありませんと
そこであんだけど それについて少々語ります
仏教ではこの信という言葉がございまして
悟りたいと瞑想する人は
5つの力つくらなくちゃいけないんです
心で 1番目は信なんですね
2番目は精進という力
1番目は信という力  2番目は精進という力
3番目は気づくという力
2番目は気づくかな サッダサティフィリエ
サマーディパンニャ  2番目は気づくという力
3番目は精進する 努力するという力
4番目は心の平安 統一集中力なんですね
5番目は知恵 この 5つの力を育てなくちゃいけないんですね
そこで一体全体 もう気づくこともわかります
努力することもわかります
ああ 集中しなきゃダメだということは一般的にはわかります
知恵がなければなかったらダメということは一応理解できますけど
一体信って何ですかと疑問が出てくる
それで それはこの前も説明した通りに
このブッダ言うんだからといって信じますよということではありません
それはもうずっと散々否定してきたんだから
散々もう馬鹿にしてきたんだから
仏教では 尊いんだ ありがたい話だからと
やっぱり信じるんだと
そんな感じで瞑想したっても
まるっきり何にもならないんです
尊い尊いと ありがたい
ありがたいとね 感謝 感謝で涙流しながら瞑想するんだと
どうったことないんです
その信は違うんです それでお釈迦様はそれには誤解するんだから
正しく これはパーリ語でアーカーラヴァティサッダと言うんです
と言います それは証拠に
証拠に基づいて至るべき確信です
至るべき達するべき確信ですね
英語でも信はフェイスビリーフではなく
コンフィデンスと訳します
パーリ経典とか訳するとか
もうこの言葉は決まっているんです
コンフィデンス 信じるんだったら
フェイスあるいはビリーフという言葉でいいんですけど
やっぱり英語で使っている言葉でもコンフィデンスなんですね
だから意味は気長くして仏教を勉強し
観察し 他の教えと比較して
最終的に真理であることに納得いくことなんですね
だから結構時間かかります
結構勉強は必要になるんですね
ですから 納得いくまで
もう刻んで刻んでむちゃくちゃにしても構いません
でも すごいやる人にもすごい
何て言いますか 精神力は必要なんです
例えば 私と反対に質問したって
私はものすごい恐ろしい答えを出しますよ
なぜかというと こちらは真理を語っているんだから
相手方が 1 年間研究して資料を持ってきたっても
こちらで一言葉で壊れる可能性はあります
そこでいきなり自信を失ったって
もう落ち込んでしまうんですね
それだったら知識人にならないんです
だから勇気が必要なんです
もし熊とチャレンジしたければ
怯えて怖くて腰抜けでできないでしょうに
相手は熊だから それだけは理解してほしい
熊というよりは 僕は象のたとえを言いたいんですけど
象さんにチャレンジしたければ
まあ相手は象さんですよ
力強いんです ですから
このたまたま大変親切に
丁寧に知りたくて質問する時もありますけど
僕はいきなり答える時もあります
時間があるんだったら丁寧に延々と説明しますけど
時間がない場合はすばりと答えちゃいますけど
すごいきついんです 自分の信仰ももう固定概念もものすごいガッタガッタ崩れますからね
だから固定概念が崩れたところで
もうどうしようもなくなっちゃいます
ですから そこはもう覚悟して
怖くはないんだと と当たってくるとわかっていくんです
そういうことで このよく研究して
研究して 調べて調べて
それから自分が達する結論に信仰というんです
だから学問的に言えば
長い間研究して達した結論のようなものなんですね
だから 我々学問的に研究して結論に立っても
その結論がだから真実やと唯一のものやってことないでしょうね
まあそうであるだろうというぐらい
だから真という言葉を使っちゃうんです
それほど強くない でもいい加減でもないんです
長い間の研究して 研究して
その研究の結果として達した結論ですから
ですから 仏教の真というのは納得いっているということなんです
納得というのは個人だから
個人でチャレンジしなくちゃいけないんですね
それであの信仰の場合も納得しているんではないかと
あれは納得じゃないんです
あれは脅し 抑えられているんです
偉大なる力で 神様や仏様やら神々やらなんか呪文やら何でもいいんです
こういうのは偉大なるパワーが力があるんだと
あ そうですかと それで信じるでしょうね
それでも抑えられているだけ
納得ではない 納得ということは
個人が自分で納得いくんです
例えば 子供に何か言う場合も
両親のパワーで抑えてこれやめなさいと言うこともできるし
あるいはよく話し合って
互いに理解し合って 子供に納得してもらう
だからその方がちょっと時間かかりますけど
根気よく気長くやらなくちゃいけないんだけど
知識の人そうやるんです
子供だからいい加減にしなさいということは言わない
私は嫌だからやめなさい
そんなことは言わない
それはもうもう性格悪い
本当の知識のある両親だったら
まあこういうことをしたらどうなると思いますかねとかね
あれはわからないんだったら
もっともっといろいろ説明してあげたりして
まあこういうエスカレートでもして
例えばちょっとした万引きしたんだとする
子供は悪いと思わない
でも万引きっていうのは盗ることでしょ
自分で買わないで だったら
まあこれはまあ ちょっと何て言いますか
あなたは万引きしたな
チューインガムぐらいかもしれませんだけど
そうやって言わないで取ることは
ただ これぐらいになったらどうしますか？と
じゃあ銀行強盗になったらどうしますか？と
人の車丸ごとに万引きしたらどうしますか？と
で 世の中にいくらでもそういう例がありますから
何々さんのことを知ってますか？と
それはいいと思いますかと
だから悪いことは小さくても大きくても
スケールの差だけであって悪いんでしょうねと
言ったら ああ そういえばそうやと
あるいはその子供の世界で
それ何か自分に嫌なことがある
例えば 子供は自分の大事に持っている宝物とかあるでしょうね
もしあなたの大事なゲームとかなんとかとかね
お父さんがあなたにも言わないで
あんた寝ている途中で持っていって誰かにあげたら
あんたどうしますか？と
それでもわからないんだったら一回やってみせる
わざと自分の大事なゲームを誰かにあげちゃう
子供探さないと そしたらなんであれを誰かにあげましたよとお父さん平気で言うと
子供は怒るでしょうね
その場合は なんてことするんですかと
パパのこと大嫌いやとかね
で ちょっと待ってくださいと
この間のことなんですけど
説明してあげることできますでしょうね
ですから それは納得いくことであって
この個人の問題なんです
自分が納得いくということは
ちゃんと証拠があって納得いくこと
ですから 仏教の信というのは矛盾ではありません
それはもう納得いくということ
だから この何かを信じることはいとも簡単ですけど
世の中でとても難しいのは仏教徒になることなんです
はい 私は仏教を信じますよと言ったって
仏教は相手にしないんです
ああそうということで
別におもしろくないと
本当のところを言うと
お釈迦様は この人は仏教の信者さんですよというのは悟った人のことなんです
悟りの段階はつがありまして
1番目にでも体験した人は
この人は信を確立しましたと言うんです
サッダージャート ですから大変なんです
だから 本当にブッダの初期仏教のことを信じている信者さんの数が少ないのは
別に泣くことでもなんでもないんです
普通なんです ただ信じるということは誰にでもできますからね
じゃあだいたいそれぐらいに言って
そこで仏教の信と信仰の違うところ
人の自由と智慧を認める
仏教は 信仰は否定するんでしょ？前説明したんだから
信仰したらもう自由がない
もう無知に基づいている
確かめようとする必要はない
確かめると信仰は足らないと言うんですね
神を確かめちゃうと それはすごい罪なんです
ですから 仏教の神は人の自由と智慧を認める
それから曖昧ではなく
知識が書いてあっても読めない
あ 確立する まずしっかりするということなんですね
知識がしっかりする 努力の結果なので
精神的に活発になる 仏教の信を作りたいと思ったら
結構頑張らなくちゃいけないんですね
だいたい人間にとっては
この他の体で頑張るよりも
いろんなことを勉強したら理解したりするとかなり気持ちいいんです
はい 一番人間幸せ感じるのは
この花を作ったり 畑を作ったりする時よりも
いろんなことを勉強したり
理解したり 知ったりする時なんですね
ものを知るということは
なんとなく楽しいんです
大体それは一番世の中にある一番楽しみなんです
ものを知ること あれも知ってやろう
これも知ってやろうと
だから私もやっぱり苦労しながら
ボーボーと文句言いながらもわからない
もう老人ですけど いろいろコンピューターをいじったりして
新しいを買ったプログラムで全くうまく動かないんですね
会社に調べてみたら あれは問題だらけだそうですね
またそれから直すんだと
で まあそういう でも やっぱり知らないことをいじったりする
知ったりするということは
どこかで楽しみなんですね
だからもう体力なくなっちゃったら大変ということで
やり始めだったら もう徹夜であろうが次の日であろうが
もう何のことなくできるんですね
やっちゃう やり始めたら
やっぱり知識っていうのは
知るっていうことはそういうことで
精神的にすごい元気になります
ですから 仏教の信というのは
人は精神的にすごい活発にします
とにかく夢中に戻す信仰の反対の性質です
ですから 信と信仰は全く正反対のことだと理解してください
あ それで終わった この
ディですね でもディも使わないと
これ あの一般的なちょっとした質問なんですけど
食べなければ饅頭がおいしいかわからないということ
宗教の何か事件が起きた
この宗教の世界でよく私にも子供の時言われたんですね
いろいろ悪口言うと 聖書なんかにはね
あんたがそれでわからないんだと
まず神様を信じてみなきゃわからないんだと
聖書で言っていることは正しいかと
結構このすごいやり合いやっていたんですね
聖書をキリスト教を勉強しながらいろんな質問すると
私も反対に質問する そこで向こうは最終的に来るのは信じなきゃ意味がないんだと
わからなくなっちゃうんだと
それに一番言いやすい反論は
まんじゅうはおいしいかないか食べなきゃわからないんだと
じゃあ それに私たちはどう答えればいいかと
だから結局それは私の立場で言えば
これは自己暗示であって
マインドコントロールです
食べてみなきゃ毒だとわからないゆえに毒を試すかと反論もできます
だから饅頭の例だったら
やっぱり食べた方がいいかとわかるんだけど
じゃあ毒の場合はどうしますか
それも食べなきゃわからないんだから
食べて死んでみなきゃ
だからそういう理屈で人は人を説得させてはいけません
でもうちょっとまだ詳しく説明するんだったら
この ある人が 例えば一生懸命子供の病気治してください
治してくださいと必死になってお祈りするとする
それで結果としてかわかりませんだけど
一応子供を治したとする
病気から立ち上がったとする
そこでその人が解釈するんですね
私はお祈りしました 子供の病気が治りました
故にお祈りは効くんだと
そこに証拠はないんです
だから 科学的に証拠をするためには
病気になっている人々はいくつか選んで
何人かが選んで 一番言いやすいのは
この全く治療不可能なガンとかなんとか選んで
あるグループにはお祈りだけする
あるグループには普通の科学的な治療をする
そうするとお祈りだけした部分グループが完璧に治ったならば
何かありそうとと思いますけど
でもそういう実験まずできませんし
だから曖昧なんですね
ただ解釈するだけ 私は聞いた話なんですけど
この本人たちに何かどこかである友人たちが事故を起こしちゃって
そこで自分だけかすり傷もなく
もううまくなんて言います
無事でした その人はそれで神を徹底的に信じているんです
私はもう自分の経験ですから
神様は信じているんだと
私から見ればあんなことほどおかしいことないんだよ
これマインドコントロールじゃないかと
だったら事故を起こしたのも神でしょうし
なんで神が一人の人がかすり傷もなく無事で
もう一人が死ぬことにするんですかね
ですから そういうのは証拠にも何にもならないんですね
一旦頭に固定概念が入っちゃったら
その固定概念でずっとみんな考えたりする
それはやっぱりマインドコントロールなんですね
例えば日本の社会のことなんですけど
宗教に対してすごく違和感
煙たいと思ってるんでしょうに
宗教ももうみんな同じで
まあやっぱりダメだ やっぱり嫌だとかね
それもいくついくつ まあマインドコントロールにもなるんですけど
本当に嫌だダメかっていうのは一つずつ調べなきゃわからないことなんですね
そういうことだから この信仰の場合は信じなきゃわかりませんよということは
仏教は全然認めません
まず疑えと 前に言ったのはそういうこと
まず疑え まず調べなさいと
それから種類のを我々間違う方法も教えてあげましたし
そこで真に至る道 仏教による真から経験に至る道
それはもう出典調べる時間がなくて
私は覚えている暗記で書いたので
少々言葉 文字の間違いがあるかもしれません
で  1番目のお釈迦様の経典にあります
サッダージャーとウパサンカメティ
サッダで真なんですけど
まず先生を信頼する とにかくそうでないと始まらないんです
先生は何か知ってるでしょうということでね
まあなんかその人知ってるでしょうと
まああれをまあ一応言ってること私はわかりませんだから
じゃあなんか勉強してみようと
そういうことで サッダージャーとウパサンカにまず先生を信頼して
そちらに行く それから 2番目
ウパサンカントダンマンスナーティ
これは仏教のことなんで
そこで彼の教えを聞く
先生のところに行って
例えばブッダのところに行って
ブッダの教えを聞く 次に
教えを覚える 何言ったんですかと
忘れるんじゃなくて きれいさっぱりと
スッタダンマンダレティ
やっぱりもったいないでしょうに
誰の話でもやっぱり聞いたならば覚えていた方が意味があるし
あの人の話聞きました
でも忘れたと この人の話も聞くわ
忘れたと言っちゃったら
聞かない人 聞かなかった人と同じだからね
まあとにかく覚えてほしいと
次に覚えたものの意味を観察する
覚えただけで止まらないで
何を言ったんですかね
本当ですかね 本当にそうなるんでしょうかねとか
自分で観察してみる ダターナンダンマ
アッタン ウパパリッキャティ
ダターナン ダンマナン
覚えた真理の意味を観察する
観察をすると理解する
納得する これ ブッダの教えの場合なんです
他の教えの場合は諦めて嫌になる可能性もあります
で アッタン ウパパリッキャト ダンマ ニッジャーナン カマティ
こちらはちょっとトラブル
これ円ではなくて円の点なんです
パーリ語の専門家の方々は直してください
あのニッジャーナン 円点書いてますけど
円点なんです うん でもこれ本当はつなげて書きますから
その場合は円になりますけどね
まあ分かれちゃうと円なんです
まあそれはまあ 文法学で関係ないんです
一応 なんで私はこのダンマニッジャーナンという言葉に線引いておいたんです
見えませんだけど そちら遠くからは
この言葉なんですね 饅頭は食べなきゃ味が美味しいかわからないんじゃなくて
やっぱり調べて 納得いったところで食べた方がいいんです
このダンマニッジャーナということは
よく仏教で使っている言葉なんですね
あなた 本当にそれでもいいと納得いってますかと
そこで納得いく 納得したっても
真理の人にはならないんですね
納得した人は努力する
それから頑張ってみなさいと
それから実験開始と 努力する
ダンマ ニッジャーナン カント ワーヤマティ
努力する 努力した人が自分で真理を体験する
ワーヤント カーエナ サッチャ
この最後の行だけ私は強引に勝手に縮めちゃったんです
原文ではそういうふうに出てこないんですから
ちょっと注意してください
で 自分で実験開始して
修行したり いろいろ試したりすると
お釈迦様がおっしゃっている悟りの真理を体験できるんです
自分で体験した 自分サチだったら別にそれで終わりだから
で ブッダと縦の関係ではなくて
そこで横に横の関係が成り立つんです
で まあそれでまあまあ
仏教の内容のまあまあ
大体もう話はそれで終わりますけど
一応お釈迦様特色なんですけど
今ここというポイントで心の平安を獲得する教えなんですね
だから天国に行ったら幸せになりますよと
後で将来いいことはあります
そういう約束は認めません
手形なんかは認めません
現金でなきゃということで
ですから ずっとお釈迦様の教えは
あの 今確かめてみてください
真理で真理であるかないか
今わかるんだと言って
このすぐの人間に幸せ
平安をすぐ体験できるように
お釈迦様が教えたものなんです
自分で体験するまで これ H なんですけど
体験できるまで 尊敬するべきものを尊敬すること
人を常識として信頼することなどは否定してはないのですと
ということは 仏教はそれほど人を信じるなと言っているんだから
頑固でわがままでいい加減でということではありません
あなたの言うことを信じません
あなたの言うことを信じませんという立場でもないんです
常識的に人を言うことは
まあなんかっていうことで
まあ一般的に常識的にいくらかは人を信じる
例えば母親が言うことは一般常識で信じる
だからって母親は絶対的な真理を語っているわけじゃないでしょ
父親が言うことをまあそれなりに信じる
会社で言うことも 社会で言うことは
まあそれなりには信じるんだけど
絶対的でそれに命かけるんだとかね
ということはないんです
ですから 目上の人は信じる
尊敬する 目上の人は何か言ったら
それはそうですか 自分では納得いってないにも関わらず
まあやっぱりやめましょうとかね
そういうことは仏教の人々も結構やってます
そこで仏教の信者の三宝に対する信仰は
このカテゴリーに入りますね
皆様はミャンマーとかタイとかね
行ってみたら ああ まあ大した変わりはないんだと
みんな信仰ばっかりではないかというふうに思うかもしれません
仏像がもういろいろもう工事やってるわ
もういろいろ大変なんで
お祭りやってるわ 宗教的な
でもあれは あれこそ真理だと思ってやってるわけじゃないんです
お釈迦様偉いんだから
まあ尊敬しましょうと拝みましょうと
お釈迦様はすごい方だから
お釈迦様のペンダントでも首にかけておこうかなとかね
それはなんとなく もうそれぐらいの
まあありがたいんじゃないかという一般的な考え方で
そこら辺は普通の人間とはそんな変わりはないんですね
でも みんなしっかりと知ってるんです
例えばタイの人々の首なんか調べたら
もう大体個  6個  8個ぐらいブッダ
いろんなペンダント見つかるんです
仏教のお坊さんの写真やらブッダの絵やら
いろんなお寺で作っているものとかね
だからってそれこそ宗教だと誰も思ってないんですね
ただありがたがってつけてるだけで
そういう信仰っていうのは
まあただ常識的にやってるだけなんですね
で そこで話を終わりますけど
で まあそれはまあ一応面白く入れただけで
お釈迦様の誕生と悟りと涅槃という 3つを一つにまとめた絵なんです
いや ありがとうございます
何か質問あるならば言ってください
ありがとうございます